what is going on there reject nation we see
doctor strange this coming monday but before that
we got ourselves another short clip and another
new trailer a featurette specifically focusing
on wanda maximoff which i hear has new footage
that we gotta check out first this obviously
can't react to this jazz once we see the movie
so we're doing it now so guys leave a like
be very much appreciated cast a spell to
that subscribe button so you'll be notified
when our review for doctor strange is
up here on the channel let's get to it
cool wow
what is grief if not love persevering that is so
cool no i love that the madness of the multiverse
is we get to see different realities
and we see different versions primarily
of doctor strange but we do see
other versions of wanda maximal
i think one division was this journey of her
for the first time taking her own life into her
own hands and it was fun transitioning from her
experience to this movie we could use an avenger
there are other avengers we'll get you back on the
lunch box what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the one division
fans and take them to the next level
with the character they love that's fun just
looking at it from a different perspective
multiverse this had his theory [ __ ] he
believed it was dangerous we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so well
it's a very powerful performance wow the very
powerful character there's some reveals in
this yeah holding the versions of everyone
it gives the characters unique
opportunity to meet themselves
to recognize qualities that they may have
been blind to afraid of them depends on us
break that four of the walls she looked right
at us yeah right at us deadpool wanda confirmed
this movie's gonna be so boring can't you
feel it i am not excited to feel how boring
this movie is gonna be imaginative too i
mean that first clip was awesome just the
different multiverses that you're going
through in this one quick action scene
that's the multiverse of madness right
here yeah that's all it was right there
the same way you saw x-men origins wolverine
trailer and you were like wow we're going to seal
up nope it's just the opening a few seconds and
we're on to the story but i love how you get all
this like crazy wildly animated versions of
it and it looks like you hop through like a
very different time period at one point like a new
timeline something yeah there's like a cyberpunk
looking city at one point too yeah there's like
a mordor hellscape this looks like mustafar from
the star wars universe hey a same umbrella company
you know it could be i really love how in a lot of
this it's really feeling like because we usually
rely on dr strange to be one who's in control
and so knowledgeable so much of the footage and
trailers that we've been getting have been putting
it back in the position where dr strange in a lot
of ways is the one who's feeling like the fish out
of water yeah absolutely like he's in way over his
head in a place that he should have a good grasp
on the person that we deem as sorcerer supreme
because he's no longer sorcerers but the one who
is he's sorcerer supreme so what do we rely on to
be the know-it-all there's so much more he has to
learn now everything that we got about wanda too
like they did confirm because there's all these
theories that have been going around is this just
some projection within her own mind this other
wanda that you see in the trailers i've been
saying and a lot of other people have been is
that that wanda who you see in the home with the
kids tommy and billy is just a wander from another
universe who seems like she was successfully
able to fulfill and have the family that she
wanted what our wanda was hoping and aiming
for and it seems like the way how dr strange
is able to experience premonition or memories
of other variants that's what wander herself
is going through so she's gonna be traversing the
multiverse trying to obtain that so it looks like
they're gonna get into like a big fight those two
wandas because somehow i i don't know exactly why
obviously there's so much i don't know about this
movie but i imagine that some ability of taking
over that oneness so she can have the children
it seems like our one is going to be turning more
villainous and that wanda when she's looking down
at her and putting her hand on her face it's like
compassionate torture like i'm sorry you can't
have children but these are my children yeah
thank you not to take them and caused your
own trauma in my life in another version of us
they mentioned vision before like viz had his
theories about the multiverse but this featurette
kicked off with what is grief if not love
persevering we still don't know if vision's gonna
show up in this movie at all but it would be so
cool to actually get him and i still think that's
not the only other wander we're gonna see oh not
at all i mean my favorite part of this actually
was kind of being reminded of how significant
i think one is gonna be in here because you
know she's in a lot of the ads and stuff but the
impression i always get is dr strange's adventure
it's gonna be confronting him as a character
we're gonna meet america's chavez wanda's gonna
be involved but this one was the first one that
really made it feel like this movie will represent
an emotional confrontation and arc for wanda as
well that feels like not only is it a sequel to
doctor strange convergence point for the greater
mcu moving forward but also a continuation of one
division that's funny because i had the exact
opposite thought i kept feeling like this is
gonna equally be doctor strange and wanda's movie
but the marketing is limiting us on wanda because
she's gonna have the biggest emotional crux to
deal with here yeah and i feel like it's a smart
choice to lean into the aspects of wanda that
are a bit more sinister and do play on the grief
that we left her in previously so that the more
nuanced and the more maybe compassionate or maybe
even more sinister versions of wanda yeah will be
a surprise for the rest of the movie and it makes
me just really excited to see what her journey
can flourish into as well because i guess maybe
it's like a perspective thing like this made me
think that maybe we'll see through her perspective
more than i was expecting of this specific movie
which i think is really nice because you know
as much as you do want it to be a doctor strange
movie that does things for him as a character i am
happy to have it be maybe while you have all these
cameos and crossovers and craziness happening
to a a real meaningful movie for wanda as well
that they could kind of share like a duet or
something like that you know almost like online
i feel like people are more excited for one of
the doctor strange man i think she's going to be
but she might be like the big highlight of the
movie and i haven't read what is in the first
20 minutes of this movie i have heard that it
is like really fast-paced and exciting that's all
i've heard about it i actually don't know what the
specifics are in there but i bet they're online in
a lot of places but guys who are you most excited
for in this film cameos or wanda leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe click
that bell leave a like hey let's shout out some
patrons andy funky punky lorenzo pretenzo baxter
differently sane and full of shame oh what the
hell levitt odell lauren american horse is snorin
farin course my hair was braided by simply
faded leave it to beaver peter pacheco delgado
nailed it joanna joe montana saint louis rogue
patrick hogue cree with bruce lee somalia justice
94 what's with all the fussin justin what are
you starting martin rosie blows me a weighty baby
darth yoder 66 colin philip joy de vivre smith
jr jen versus ryu and ken smith with tell me your
thoughts melanie leblanc the player eva drastico
found alive in sokovia jason takes manhattan dolan
thank you guys for being here and hopefully
we bring you cheers hooray see you next month